every day i wake up the first thing i
think
am i going to be able to talk today
there's been a red card but for who
chris tamara
i don't know jeff hazard one of
britain's best love football pundits
it's been a great job
unbelievable jeff what a cracking game
there's a young black kid thinking that
one day i'll play four middles
middlesbrough and four leads ambition
and dream
achieved
the story of your mother i found very
difficult to read it was difficult in
those days
men
were physical towards women i made the
mistake
of
telling my dad on his deathbed that it
was wrong
i should have kept it to myself
[Music]
why
for someone that has never experienced
apraxia
what does it feel like for you and your
head
i feel a fraud now in terms of
broadcasting you feel a fraud
i
was gonna quit everything
without further ado i'm stephen bartlett
and this is the diary of a ceo i hope
nobody's listening but if you are then
please keep this to yourself
[Music]
chris
what do i need to know about
your earliest years to understand
the man that you are today
whoa i don't know really um
my childhood is slightly clouded um
so
i wouldn't change anything because you
can't change the
course of history but
life was difficult growing up very
difficult um
so yeah
i wouldn't change anything to be honest
when you say clouded
well good days bad days we had uh
terrible racism at the time uh when i
was growing up i was born in 57
so in the 60s it wasn't good we were the
only black family on our estate
so anything happened and the police
would come knocking on our door take out
that away and you'd have to get cleared
and
come home and the whole process would
start again it's that black family there
who are causing all the problems
and
occasionally uh not all the time
my dad
were like to bet
so he would
on a thursday he when he got paid they
got paid in cash and then brown
envelopes
would occasionally go to the bookies and
so
we'd end up
you know struggling for food so it's
clouded in those ways
i'm looking through those clouds now but
you know
uh
thinking it didn't do me any harm but it
happened you know
your mother and your father's
relationship
uh
mum was the
most loyal wife you could ever have
absolutely even if her and dad
and arguments are fights or whatever
she would
venemently stick up for him you know
when anybody called him you know
the n-word was vibrant back in those
days
and you know i hear these stories now
that
it's impossible to understand
uh
racism if you're not black it's not true
it's totally not true
my mom got colder and lower
throughout
you know the 60s when i was aware of it
uh and she came through it so she knew
exactly what racism was about
your father was from sierra leone yeah
and your mother was from
middle flow middlesbrough yeah
people don't always think about that
they don't think about how the
in in that context because my mother's
from nigeria and my dad's from coventry
so i'm
you know and
what my
dad went through as well because his
wife was black
um is often not spoken about but often
the the partner
carries the weight and the the um
the insults all the same
i i was reading through your story about
how your mother would also on thursday
she would walk up to 10 miles
to go and get your dad's
pay packet yeah through fear that he
might spend it yeah she had to and so it
became a ritual in the end she would do
it all the time in the end when we were
older as kids she didn't have to carry
us to
the uh workplace which was 10 miles away
uh
a brown journey and
so
she they ended up she would walk to meet
dad and they would go off into town
together you know and that became the
norm
did your dad ever show the
impact or the consequences of the way he
was being treated like an outsider in a
country where he people were telling him
he didn't belong
uh
to us as kids did you ever see the
impact of him emotionally
did it manifest itself in drinking or
was there ever a sign that it was
impacting him uh he told us often enough
he'd been involved in
fights uh
back then fist fights you know that was
the norm you know he had to stand up and
be counted but he was always the one
arrested in those fighting situation
um but he
he had this thing and he drove it into
me and my brother don't ever
react you know i might be reacting
but whatever you do don't react you know
take it on the chin
and ride through it
you'll get through it that way it's been
harder for me
and i'm doing this for you so
yeah you'll benefit
and money
you know the other thing that i read
that i found i found really difficult to
read was the story of your
your mother
when
your dad's gambling
problems
were very difficult your mother would
and you didn't have money your mother
would go around to other houses in the
street and knock on the doors and ask
for bread or anything or money that's
how it had to be you know if you've got
tuesday and wednesday to come
on a monday and you haven't got food and
milk and until dad gets paid on thursday
she'd go and borrow
money or milk or bread
from the neighbors she had to she got
turned away more often than not but she
persevered she had to she had to look
after her kids
how did you feel amongst that time see
what agu at this point five six seven
eight
um
well yeah
it wasn't all the time you know it was
occasional so
yeah i would say
from eight-year-old i became aware of it
more uh
i know it's eight because i had to light
a cold fire at eight years of age
can you imagine you know i can imagine
asking my boys
to get wood and paper and matches and
then light the paper and then once the
wood gets going put the coal on top at
eight years age yeah yeah
[Music]
spooky yeah
you were asked to do that to heat the
home yeah
they we didn't have sensual heating he
had a fire coal fire that was all yeah
you had the
oven in the
back of the house in the kitchen so
you'd put the
gas on to heat the kitchen when it was
really cold but the main source of heat
and the hot water was the fire
was there was there a lot of love in
your home
uh
yeah i would say intimately yeah yeah
yeah you know when i look back now
um
i would change anything even though
there are aspects that i'd like to
change
one or two one or two things you know
what
the thing i want don't want to do is
is
destroy
the
person who my dad is for my grandkids
but it was difficult in those days you
know
men
were physical towards women
uh so yeah
yeah uh difficult yeah
i sat here not so long ago with alex
scott
the the um football presenter
broadcasting yeah i worked with alex at
sky
yeah her book comes out in 10 days time
in the book i was reading about how um
she's never spoken about it before
publicly but
she would come home and watch her father
beating her up her mother
constantly
and the mark that left on her as a young
child having to witness that kind of
violence in the home
and it's not really talked about enough
and it's funny the reason why i bring
that up is because
she's also grappling with the same um
fear of
tarnishing her father's
life
yeah
yeah but it was done i presume
my dad grew up with it
and so you thought it was okay
for him to do it but like i say
you know
my kids will probably listen to this and
you know i don't want to say too much on
it is there a mixture of emotions around
it because that's what i observed in
alex as well was there's this like
you look at someone in your life whether
it's a parent or someone you love and
you say that behavior was wrong
but at the same time
i i love you you're still my father
and it's you know that that balancing
act of like should i hate this person
should you never say
yeah
i made the mistake
of
telling my dad on my death on his
deathbed
uh
that it was wrong
and he
he
saw like wouldn't accept that he'd done
what he'd done so
you know
why does that make you emotional
well
i should have kept it to myself
why
why wait until he's nearly dead
to say something i'm a grown man in this
time
your mother
yes
puts a smile on your face yeah of course
um what role has she played in making
you the man you are today
um
she was everything
you could want in a mom
she would do anything for me
um she did
my dad never saw my school report from
the age of five until i left school at
16.
she protected me that way and so yeah
but not only that you know
my mums are great and
she looked after the family um
as good as she possibly could and
you know
she was my world
and at that age what was your what were
your dreams
if i'd asked you the question what do
you want to be when you grow up yeah
footballer yeah no danger
playing for middlesbrough initially and
then
when i saw leads on back to the day
around there may sounds
boring all leads yeah ambition to play
for borah dream to play for leagues so
footballer nothing else tunnel vision
yeah
why
football what was it doing for you oh
everything yeah i used to play
on the field near
our house
with again squirrel men from the age of
12
and i wasn't bad you know and they would
try to kick lumps out of this little kid
who was embarrassing him so
yeah it stood me in good stead
when i played against men at 16
i couldn't look after myself
eventually you um you end up going and
doing a couple of months in the army
yeah the navy
yeah
no um
uh dave richardson
uh who was uh
uh coach middle
boys
came around my house and said to my dad
uh there's a chance not guaranteed that
chris will be taken on uh as an
apprentice a middlesbrough and he went
no
no he's not going
if he stays in middle row
he'll become uh
he'll be in trouble with police uh he'll
end up drinking and stuff like that he's
not staying in middlesbrough he's going
in the navy he made my brother join the
army
and he made me join the navy
literally
frog marched me down to the recruitment
office and the sign on the dotted line
can you imagine you know well i can't
imagine doing that to my kids you know
and in a way i think that worked against
me with my kids
because
i never pressurized my kids to do
anything at all
you know let them
do whatever they wanted whereas
i probably could have been a you know
a little bit more
in terms of football or
you know
but i want whatever they wanted to do
was my wish and i think that came from
my dad
when he marched you down there and you
had a love for football at that time he
marched you down there and he wanted you
to join the navy
how did you feel
um
not good i have to say not good um
it was
one of those things i left middlesbrough
boys were
in a semi-final um the week before i was
going in the navy so i knew
i had this final coming up when i signed
a semi-final coming up when i signed uh
for the navy
so i was thinking hopefully the
semi-final and final
yeah of the middle boys
uh will be over
but i played the semi-final and then
i didn't uh get in touch with dave
richardson to tell him i wouldn't be
there for the final because i was off to
tall point in devon
uh well como it's across the water from
plymouth um that's where i'm from
plymouth yeah plymouth yeah so you know
it's comal and not devon yeah but it's
uh it's a stone's throw
and uh that's where i got my lucky break
yeah
your lucky break
yeah when the navy football team were
training there so uh
i went down um
one day
and uh i asked the coach if i
could train with him and the team and he
went now
three reasons one you're on
a trial
so
yeah what it did you were on a trial
situation whereas
you got to
six weeks whether you liked the navy or
they like you and if not you could leave
so he said come back in six weeks
uh if you want and the other thing he
said number two
he said is your black and these lot are
kick lumps out of you so to speak
so and the third thing is you're too
skinny you're not gonna be strong enough
to play in the
uh navy football team so i said okay
anyway got to six weeks
was fine uh was okay
and then
there's a six months
period then where you can decide if you
want to stay in the navy or not
so
uh i went back to see him and he kept
saying no no no and then one day i was
running around the track while the navy
football team and he said look we're two
players short i'll play on one side you
play on the other just stay out on the
wing and you'll be fine
so i said okay anyway i scored two goals
from the wing
and got drafted straight into the team
straight away and
the rest is
history
we played
portsmouth
reserved
and um
navy side i scored another two goals
against them they asked how old i was
and
they bought me out for the
magnificent sum of 200 pounds
and
my dad um
i i found my dad and i told him what was
happening
and he wasn't happy so
i spoke to the navy and said look
would you do me a favor would you give
me a letter saying if it don't work out
as a footballer i can go back in the
maybe and they said yeah fine
so
i got that letter
uh
sent it to dad and it sounded like made
him
you know a bit more cell
hmm
and then it happens your your career
portsmouth
a lot of people don't um
a lot of people will never appreciate
especially in this the modern era even
me even me as a guy that has a a black
black mother and a white father the what
racism was like back in the 50s and 60s
you know the first time i experienced
racism was
maybe 1990
eight
no it would have been later a little bit
about 2000 roughly about when i was
maybe eight or nine or ten but when i
was reading through what you experienced
at that in that time
almost constantly yeah yeah i just it
it's it makes it almost makes my
experience feel like it was nothing
and i mean that like i remember like
once or twice or three times you know
over the course of my whole childhood
people being overtly racist
but when was the first time someone was
racist to you
i know exactly when it all scanner never
forget it
i was eight years old once again that
was the time where i could light the
fire and go to the shops to get
cigarettes so you went with a note for
the shopkeeper
so it was
10 wood vines for my mum
and 20 capstan full strength
my dad
so i went to the shop
gave the note to the shopkeeper
uh and he's getting in this woman uh
came in the shop
anyway she asked for a pint of milk or
loaf of bread i'm not sure of those
details
and uh he said i am i'm serving this
young man here
she said isla should
go back to where they came from
and i thought i live five dollars away
from you you know
uh i'm not you know from somewhere else
and he said no look he stood his ground
the shopkeeper and served me and i went
out with uh ringing in our ears and then
blacks and souls
shouldn't be here
it says it all that you can remember
that day with such detail
[Music]
i can yeah
that's something i don't think people
realize is the first time someone called
me in the n-word at school i remember
everything about that day i can't
remember many other days but for some
reason that was a it's a very traumatic
experience
and the first sort of signs that you're
different yeah unwelcome
um
and that would go on to continue
throughout your
childhood your football career
i read about the story when you were
playing against millwall i believe it
was
and someone had thrown a banana on the
pitch at you um
yeah no wall was
horrific but not just for me as a black
person it was for any footballer that
went there you know basically but even
harder for me i can always remember uh
once again if you ask me about my career
and there's you know lots i forget but
the first time i took a throw in there
the ball went out
and they kept the wall initially it
wouldn't give me it and then eventually
got through on to the pitch
and the
uh
um
fans uh virtually there and you're
taking a throwing from there so i'm sort
of like taking this throwing and all of
a sudden spit is on the back of my the
packet much
i never took a throwing ever there again
that lesson was truly learnt yeah
and the the the other story which i
found it just sounded like something
from
a thousand years ago was when you went
to the pub after a game
with your team and the the pub owner
made a comment a racist comment to you
yeah yeah that was in wetherby i'd
played for portsmouth at sunderland
um
and
1976
i think sunderland needed to win to get
promotion to the what is the premier
league now the old first division
we needed a win to stay up
in the old second division
what is the championship now anyways
sunderland won
that day
i always remember that game
for two reasons not just the weatherby
incident
i drank champagne for the first time
uh sunderland sent a case of champagne
into the dressing room because they got
promoted that day
so
we get on the coach uh every
virtually every team that played
sunderland on newcastle would stop at
whether before fish and chips
um
so uh
so we stop so we all pile in the pub uh
most of the players
and the barman says we don't serve his
kind in here
and
the lights were all gone and i went no
no no it's fine uh to be honest i was
underage anyway i was 17. um
but that didn't matter back then i'd
been going in the pubs since i was 14
you know
um so i went no no it's fine anyway
mickey mello's one of my teammates
said i'll bring you a pint out but that
was the first time that my teammates
realized you know do you get that often
and stuff like that
they're saying yeah occasionally you
know but
part of life you know
you get on with it
it's one thing to to shrug it off and i
feel like in that situation
there's a time in place you know
to um to address some of these things or
to confront them
your father had taught you to kind of
not react as you say
but as you look back on that period of
your life
how did that racial abuse shape and
change you as a man
uh
it made you wary of other people
obviously
you know
not happy but i wouldn't say oh god it's
traumatized me or
something like that
and then the
black lives come out and people start
telling their stories of
racism
and the way they've been treated and you
think ah why can't i tell my story now
and i have them
[Music]
has that helped you telling your story
to be honest i wouldn't say it's helped
me out not help me
i think
since i've had this
well i've got two conditions an
underactive thyroid and
apraxia
the underactive the thyroid
plays with your emotions
so
i get a lot more emotional now whereas
stuff i wouldn't even bat an eyelid in
the past because of this little
butterfly
uh thyroid in my neck it now
makes me more emotional
when did you discover the underactive
thyroid uh well
it's funny you know it's really funny um
it's
i did
going through lockdown initially the
first lockdown in march
uh when the weather was great and
everyone you know quite
you know i think they were gutted about
the lockdown but the fact you were at
home and the sun was shining
things were slightly different i did
loads and loads of shows from home you
know
celeb use and steph's back launch itv
lorraine and stuff like that sky sports
from the you know
barn at home
you know so that was fine
so uh
all of a sudden i began
to not feel well
um
too well but i always stroked it off i'd
take you know
tablets and be fine the next day and all
that sort of stuff but it wasn't going
away
and uh
i thought
what's going on but i ignored it ignored
it which is the worst thing you can
possibly do
so i would get away with it at home by
hardly not being the person i was you
know i'm not talking as much when i'm
broadcasting for sky
i'm trying to keep minimalistic because
some of the words are coming out slurred
and stuff like that so
eventually
um
i've got to go and see someone because
i literally went
a whole year if not 20 months
before
i actually
got diagnosed with underactive thyroid
so
it was all my prayers answered at once
uh
you know
you've got an underactive thyroid take
level thyroid
once you find your level of level of
thyroxine you'll be fine
great doctors great uh sorting out so
eventually you take 25
grams or whatever it is a level entire
auction
eventually when you find your level
you're fine so i get to 175
and my thyroid is stabilized
bull
my voice condition is still exactly the
same so what's going on
so my doctor then says go for a brain
scan
so i'd go for a mri scan anyway
go and see a brain specialist he looks
at the
x-rays the mri scan fine not a problem
nothing wrong with your brain it's got
to be something else that's going on
so uh
go back to my gp and tell him what's
going on he's got the report
from the brain scan so he says he he
won't give up my gb
he says
it's not obviously your uh thyroid
there's something else going on
would you go and see this doctor lily
and late he's a specialist
so i'll go and see dr lily in leads and
before
uh alboni said hello to him uh and
before i can even chat to him he says
you've got apraxia
of speech
right how do you know i can tell
straight away the difficulty between
the brain and your mouth being able to
speak you know it's probably slower than
it is now uh at that time
so he said a lot you know i want you to
go and have a dat scan which is which
rules out parkinson's or stroke and all
that so so
i did uh went back to see him with the
result for the results i should say
and he went
the good news is
uh you haven't got
parkinson's or anything like that the
bad news is
you know
we can't find anything else wrong with
you so
you know the apraxia
you know will probably get worse
and uh
and
you know
that went on for
quite a while uh
i went to see a therapist
and he kept saying to me look you need
to tell people you know you can't
continue
on tv and people are saying is he drunk
and what's the matter with him has he
had a stroke
you need to
come out and say something i said i
can't i can't i'd rather quit
than
actually say something
uh
anyway eventually
i
spoke to my mate ben sheppard
uh
told him what was going on so he said
look
come on
uh gmb
uh
we'll chat about it and
let the world know
what's going on
how are things for your your family
during this period
um
my boys had been saying to my wife that
something wrong with that uh
for a while
and
she saw like
would broach it with me but i'd be
quite snappy and you know which i'm not
anyway
you know and say no i'm fine i'm fine
don't worry about it i'm fine
and i kept thinking like i said once i
got the thyroid problem the level will
tie rocks
i'll take it away
and then
um
it's still with with me and
yeah
yeah
it's harder for people close to you i
think you know because
my two boys are saying oh you're okay
oh yeah i'm fine i've just had a bad day
you know don't worry i'll be fine uh but
they know you know
you can't pull the ball over their eyes
for too long
for someone that has never experienced
what it's like to have apraxia
what does it feel like for you in your
head
it feels like
someone is taking over my voice books
so
the
voice that used to come out would come
out at 300 mile an hour you know you've
seen me on the
results and
uh soccer saturday you know my mouth
talking uh
not even waiting for a breath just keep
going and going
now when i hear myself or see myself on
tv it's someone else
it's strange it's really strange
some days you know their message from
the brain to the mouth
is really slow yeah
makes it difficult or some days the
words come out different that what
you're trying to say and that's even
weirder
uh and so that's been hard to accept
and still hard to accept i have to say
you know
i
was gonna quit everything you know
literally every single
tv at the end of last season leave sky
uh quit bbc quit itv quit channel four
and five
and all those companies
uh
bbc i think it was the right time to
leave sky
uh i'd had a great innings but
itv channel on channel 5 said no no
you're coming doesn't matter you know i
said well it's the quality of the
program no it doesn't matter
you you're fine we want you to do this
and would you believe i'm now
doubly busy than what i was before
that that period of um
uncertainty you get the diagnosis
the specialist says to you it's only
going to get worse
[Music]
your career is at that point in
speaking
it's in presenting broadcasting yeah
what's what what was that period of
uncertainty like on your mental health
um
yeah it was uh an acceptance really
because what i said to my wife is if i
wasn't a broadcaster it wouldn't matter
would it
and so she said yeah yeah so i said you
know now's the time i've had a great
time i spoke to my agent
simon dent said look i'm getting out of
all this
and he said yeah you can yeah don't
worry
i'll leave it up to you and uh
yeah i thought that's it quit i've done
my time
and
i'd like to thank all the people
that are being persistent and said look
at 25 percent coming years
you know
still better than some people you know
and skye
saw you on that show forever
um yeah presenting and bringing you know
insights and wisdom and laughs and
um all of that to the show
i also watched the tribute um that jeff
jeff did when you left what was that
like having to to speak to
to jeff and and the rest of the lads and
tell them
departing and for the reason um well
jeff's a really close foul and he knew
that been something going on for a while
and he kept saying to me are you all
right and i said yeah i'll find you
don't worry i'm fine you say well you
know
yeah what's going on so i said honestly
just had a couple of bad days and stuff
but i'll be fine on saturday then he'd
send me a text and say you know fine
again no i said i'll be all right next
week or whatever but
yeah you can't pull the wool over
people's eyes who know you real well and
uh it was great you know
the tribute that skye gave me which
like i said was the right time to leave
there
uh i cried when he cried on the show
i've never seen him cry before
he's a really um
beautiful powerful moment
um
since then
you've uh in your own words you've
really thrown the kitchen sink i think
is the quote um
um the apraxia and can you talk to me
about what you've done since to
to um
mitigate the
impact of the
um
condition on you and your life and your
career
yeah the um the day i went on
gmb and spoke to ben sheppard
um
and kate um
the i got a phone call immediately from
a fella that i knew
ish
uh a fellow called winford doors and uh
he said uh
i can cure you you know i know there's
people out there that'll help
to get you right
so
he said
i want you to come and meet a professor
nicholson down at sheffield university
so i said okay so i met winford and the
professor anyway between them they were
saying
you need to kickstart your cerebellum
which is in the back of the brain
uh what's happened is uh it's shut down
so we need to get the jump leads out
start it again and get your brain going
and get your speech going
and uh there are various ways to do that
[Music]
so
so i said yeah what are those i'll do
absolutely anything here to try and get
it right
so
he got
[Music]
zing performance which is really
exercises for stroke victims but it's
helped my balance
uh
arc performance which is micro currents
going through my body i still i have
a tag on my
ankle now with those micro currents
going through all the time yeah all the
time yeah
uh for seven hours every day
um and it's helped
yeah it's helped you know i'm
i wouldn't say um
more than 60 percent
the old me but
you know i was 20
you know so i've gone up 40
for a
hyperbaric uh tent you know with the
oxygen he recommended
i do that and i see a therapist
who helps with the speech and help my
anxiety working for sky
became very difficult you know
before i
even
came out and said i've got it
my heart would be like mad before they
came to me at sky
oh the anxiety was terrible because i
was
knowing i wasn't the old me
so i went to see him and he said look i
can cure that
the other problem the apraxia is a
biological condition so i can't help
with that but
we'll try you know and see if we can get
you through things
so getting rid of the anxiety helped me
finish work or
the
work i had stacked up uk strongest
mountain the games right tv
uh all those shows cash in the attic i
present
um
so they helped me do that um
and uh all those
um
treatments you know i'm taking so many
vitamins these days and uh
i've just been introduced by winford
uh to uh
the
uh
best neurologist neurologist
in america and
he said because i have good days there's
no reason why i can't be cured
so i've sent off a load of blood tests
and everything to america and i'm just
waiting on the results
how is life for you now
you've been through a journey yeah you
know
where are you in in that journey now
strange uh
strange in terms of
i feel a fraud now in terms of
broadcasting i don't bring
to the table what i used to
um so that's hard
my life away from the screen
couldn't be any better
you know grandkids
you know family yeah
it's
you know it's perfect unique yeah
you feel afraud
yeah
um
because you because you
i feel i'm doing these programs and
and they're not getting the best of me
but they're tolerating me you know
that's how it feels
i mean
who am i to say but um you know i
i think what you what they told you
about
as you said 25 of you is better than
pretty much everyone else
you know i've you you've brought so much
joy to my life growing up made me love
the game more made me understand the
game more you've made it hilarious i
mean you know that you're you're loved
more than anyone i've ever seen on the
screen so
and you've earned that that's a skill
that's something i couldn't do
i wouldn't know how to do a slither of
what you do so
i don't think that um i suspect that
fear is is not as logical as you think
it is that you're a fraud
i mean that as well like i could never
do what you do i can do of 10 of what
you do
so um
you know
it's like anything else you take it for
granted your old self you do things
you know
that tribute that skye gave me
that's
reserved for someone who passes away
isn't it you know so i've had the
tribute while i'm still alive
uh that people don't get when they go
you always look back and think you read
the obituaries and the comments and
things why didn't people say that
you know so
i think
maybe i should have bowed out
then
you know and
taking the accolades and said thank you
you know am i tarnishing
what i've got what i had
but i but i think um my rebuttal to that
if i may is that you you're serving the
world in a very important way now still
even by having this conversation and
being vulnerable and open
you are serving hundreds of thousands of
people
thousands and thousands of people in a
completely entirely different way
that are suffering
with with various conditions whether
it's
you know as you said post-stroke victims
or whether it's apraxia or other things
and they're struggling with the same
self-doubt
it's funny like our missions just change
over our lives right like so your first
missions was in football and then you
became a manager then you did
broadcasting and now this chapter of
your life is just a different chapter
you're still you know a wondrous
broadcaster but you're serving people in
a completely other way probably maybe
arguably even in a more important way
see what i mean yeah
yeah i do
yeah
it's funny i did the itv games and
a youtuber who was called young philly
i'd never met him before but he's on the
first show
and he sees me before we go broadcasting
and he comes over and he starts doing
that he went you're a god
when
what
you know
i'm young philly pleased to meet you
do you know what icon you are for black
people
that went nah don't be darby you are
you're a trailblazer
you know you did tv before diversity
you know how did you get into tv when
you you know on sky sports and there was
no black people around and all that so
stuff you're an
icon and i went no i don't see myself as
uh anyway well you'd be my inspiration
so
makes you feel good for a second that's
worth it right yeah
and that alone that that thought that
you're inspiring people just by having
this conversation
and by sharing your story and being
honest and not running into the shadows
as you could have very easily done
is gonna help that and you probably
never get to meet them like you got to
meet young philly
hmm but that's got to be worth it right
yeah
yeah it was i didn't believe him but
yeah
he's got no reason to lie though
quick one as you might know crafted are
one of the sponsors of this podcast and
crafted are a jewellery brand and they
make really meaningful pieces of
jewellery and this piece by crafted when
i put it on for me it represents courage
it represents ambition it represents
being calm and loving and respectful and
nurturing while also being the
antithesis of that seemingly the
antithesis of that which is um sometimes
a little bit aggressive with my goals
and determined and courageous and brave
the really wonderful thing about crafty
jewelry is it's super affordable it
looks amazing the pieces hold tremendous
meaning and they are really well made
this next uh this next chapter
what what what do you want it to be full
of
my life has changed uh in terms of
grandkids
you know material things
don't matter anymore um
the love yeah for
you know your kids kids uh is something
else so
you know
i'm one of those now
even though i'm still working my main
priority is spending time with them
what advice would you give me
you know i just turned 30
last week
what advice would you give me i say it
to everyone
work hard and you'll succeed
don't ever turn down work
don't ever say on a job or this is hard
i don't like it anymore i can't do this
do it
do it and do it to the best of your
ability and see where it takes you you
know
tv
is
one of those jobs i think where if you
work hard enough you'll succeed
in football that's not the case you know
i've grown up in football and you
sometimes a lucky break is better
than working hard even you've still got
a workout but you need breaks
and of course you need breaks in tv but
if you work hard
i think you get them i started off at
sky
and so
people say how did you get into sky in
1998
well
initially
i was a pundit forum
i was lucky fortunate the first
broadcast of the
football league was sunderland versus
sheffield united at sheffield
and they rang me i was manager of the
month with bradford
in
[Music]
august we won four games and drew one
and they called me and said would you
come and be the pundit
so i said yeah sheffield down the road
from me and they said no
you've got to come into sky
in west london so i came all the way
down
marcus brooklyn the presenter who is his
first day and it was a double header six
hours of tv
obviously ads in between and all that
sort of stuff half time
and that and jerry francis was doing the
second game
so that's where fate took a hand
uh i did the first game sunderland won
at sheffield
and jerry francis got stuck on the m4 so
i did the double header so
from doing six hours of tv i became the
go-to guy then for sky so a live game
are you available
uh yeah i'll come down and do it and i
did that
and then when i got the sack from
bradford they asked
would i like a contract and i said no
but i like to keep my face in the shop
window
so i did one broadcast and then stoke
came along
and i got that job
and then that job turned sour pretty
quickly after three months
and uh
then
i just fell straight into sky
the broadcasting
and
so
eventually um
the 1999
the producer of soccer side he said
would you like to come and join the team
uh so i said yeah so you went would you
like to do some features for us
so i would actually go and train with
teams premier league teams you know can
you cannot imagine in a million years
that they let you in and train with the
players these days but i did that back
in the day 1990 you know so i'd go on
train joining the training with them
interview the managers the players shoot
the
and then i
went and edited those pieces
because i didn't want someone saying oh
yeah it's fine but you know the hard
work is done by the editor
so i would sit myself in a studio
and
sometimes it took six seven hours for a
four minute piece to edit it down
but i thought all right i don't want
anyone saying he's there by for all
hard work
and if you do that people see that
uh
it'll help not in all cases but in most
cases
that was the very start of what would go
on to be a legendary career in the media
um
i
when you look so you've given me one
reason now as to why you're successful
which is just the hard work and saying
yes
but the media business is also
it's much more complex than that in the
sense that hard work as you say is like
you definitely need to do it but
what was it about you
do you think that set you apart
as of as a in the media industry as a
broadcaster
i don't know that i'm still baffled by
that i went to ian condren's
uh
40th anniversary with his wife he was
ian was the producer of soccer sadie who
gave me the job
and
[Music]
i said
why you know
i'd seen you on doing other programs
punditry and so you'd be great for our
show
he said uh you know took a chance with
you and uh
and it works for 20 years
you mustn't you must have a suspicion
no no no at all you know i'm i was
allowed to be just me
so
i didn't have to work at it like i had
to work it
editing those pieces together you know
the training plan
uh interviewing the managers all came
natural yeah it was that hard work that
i wanted to prove that i could do um but
no
i was fortunate oh it was just me
and
when did you meet anne uh we met uh
when i was at swindon
uh i got transferred from
uh portsmouth
to swindon my first ever transfer
and uh
in 1978
[Music]
1978 yeah 1978
and uh we actually
played portsmouth
my first game
for swindon was
home to portsmouth
and
yeah i had to uh please escort to the
game um
the
uh club had been informed by the
intelligence
that the national front because
portsmouth had 200 national front
supports national front is this racist
organization from yeah couple decades
ago yeah
so
they'd got wind that they were
gonna do me in you know
um so uh
you know when i played for pompey there
was a small section of fans that
booed you onto the pitch because of your
color booed you off
you know but like i said back in those
days
i didn't care not one job you know and i
didn't care when they said about this
you know you're gonna be nothing and i
said oh it's just a threat don't worry
about it but the police intelligence
said no
we need to pick you up
and
take you to the game and drop you back
home
so i did and
uh he scored went to the year after 10
minutes
and not like today uh where
people don't celebrate uh of course
stupid me you know dad this death threat
goes straight because i scored in the
end where the pompey fans were
and
gave it all that
so uh
so yeah no
so uh the police escort wanted to take
me back to my dicks but i said no
leave it now it's fine
and uh one of my teammates
kenny stroud
his wife linda was with
uh this girl called on
uh and uh i asked her out and
you know 40 years later or 43
years later
we're still together
what a journey it's been
a long journey yeah
what does she mean to you
uh everything you know
it's
you take
wives from grant and all i did you know
i can't speak for everyone else
um
but it's only when
you have a problem like this because
you know
i
just live for today you know i'm fine
i'm you know i'm
no problems don't worry about me
so it's when you have a problem
um that you have to
you know look at your closest one and
see what they do for you and
how they react
to what you're going through which
you know
is difficult and then you feel
sad about you know not sharing things
before and keeping things away from
how did she react to all of this
um
she
she said
she thought for a while she didn't say
anything
she said she sought
uh for a while
there was something not quite right but
she couldn't put her finger on it
and she's been my rock you know now
you know
i don't i don't hardly you know this is
the longest i've spoken to anybody for a
long time you know
and you'll probably see when you edit
this tape
sometimes it's slow sometimes it's
coming out okay now it's coming out okay
and it feels fine you know and that's
all to do with the mind
maybe i'm talking about a good thing now
with ants so it's fine and it's free
so yeah she's
you know she's taking the
weight
uh a heavy weight of my shoulders
and
you know allowed me
to do what i do
to continue doing what i'm doing if i
want to do it
but she does say from time to time
you're allowed to say no to these jobs
that simon rings up and asked me to do
but i don't like to let anyone down
you know i think it's worth saying that
i think this this has been a really
really great conversation
um and uh
i'm actually quite surprised to hear
that of how much you struggled
previously based on with the
conversation we've had today
because i don't
um
i don't i don't know if i'm speaking out
turn here but had i not known about the
um the condition
this would have been a perfectly normal
conversation on this on this podcast so
it's really really interesting and
enlightening to
to learn more about it and i
yeah i can't imagine as from a family's
perspective as well going through that
journey with their father where you're
trying to find answers you find answers
and then there's that whole sort of
therapy process to get you back to where
you are and the mental health
journey that takes us on which we've not
really talked about in detail but
there's the curing the the condition but
then there's like living with the cost
of
the shift the tectonic shift in your
life
um
it consumed your mind or asda
mine
so
every day i wake up the first thing i
think
am i gonna be able to talk today you
know so
immediately i wake up i'll go in the
bathroom and i'll look in the mirror and
say a few words and
it's fine or i think it's fine
the perception is fine in my head and
then i'll go downstairs and
talk to anne and all of a sudden that
pathway is
restricted and oh god not again today
you know and that's been hard to get my
head around
and my therapist uh daniel
he says you exaggerate
in your mind you know that's the problem
because you've never had to think about
your speech now you're thinking and
you're overthinking so even though like
you've said
it seems fine to you in my head i know
that it's slower
than
it would have been had we spoken three
years ago
and that the cognition part the thoughts
that they're still the same
yeah they're they're lightning quick
yeah they're fine
so uh
they're there in terms of speech but
i have days where
if you're out and about or
even indoors there's nothing in the
brain area so
you know whereas
i could normally go into a room
did it all the
time
speak to everyone have a laugh that was
the first thing on my mind
now
that
part of it is hard work
and it feels hard work and it feels this
struggle and it doesn't feel natural
that's the worst thing
so i tend not to do it very often you
know unless
i'm feeling good i've you know
spoken to someone else and
i can tell it's fluid
uh the voice then i'll go in a room and
be myself again
chris we have a closing tradition on
this podcast yes where the um
last guest asks a question for the next
guest they don't know who they're
writing it for
and they'll never find out
um although i have said their name
earlier on so you might be able to
figure it out right
but um
the question they've written for you is
i'm going to read it verbatim what has
been the most happiest
moment of your life
full stop brought you the most joy
and why
uh is that kids aside
or let's say kids aside because yeah
yeah yeah kids aside
uh achieving my ambition and my dream
yeah
i can you know as a young black kid
playing
on the fields around where i live
thinking that one day
i'll play an awesome park for
middlesbrough and ellen wrote four leads
it's blown my mind away you
know uh ambition and dream
achieved
chris thank you i am i have no doubt
that
your ambitions and dreams are are just
getting started because you have all of
the the core the minerals that it are
required to achieve pretty much anything
and you've shown that your life has been
a testament to that even in the face of
great adversity
thank you i thank you not just for
myself and for you giving me your time
today but
um i don't think you realize how many
people you're going to help in a really
important profound way how much pain
you're going to alleviate from them how
you're going to make them feel seen and
understood just by doing this today and
just by not hiding in the shadows thank
you so thank you and thank you for all
the joy you've brought me you've made
football fun
you've made it um
made me understand the game better over
the course of pretty much my entire life
um so i'm for one i'm so glad that i
still get to see you on the screens and
i hope to see you a lot more i know you
guys showed ninja warrior uk race for
glory um which is airing on itv which
i'm very excited about watching as well
yeah i'm so glad i did it you know i
tried to pull out
when they rang me and said
we've been commissioned for series seven
i went oh no and they what what do you
mean oh no now when oh no you're not
getting the old coming they said oh
don't worry about it
and uh
i've watched a bit of the first episode
and even though it don't sound like me
it's passable you know so
yeah i hope people enjoy it well as you
said 25 percent of you is better than
pretty much most anyone else so
we'll take that thank you so much chris
thanks
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast for many years
people have been asking for a coffee
flavored huel and quite recently he'll
release the iced coffee caramel flavor
of their um ready-to-drink heels and
i've just become hooked on it over the
last couple of weeks i've been on a
really interesting journey with huel
which i've described and talked about a
little bit on this podcast i started
with the berry ready to drinks then i
moved over to the protein salted caramel
because it's 100 calories and it gives
you all of your essential vitamins and
minerals but also gives you the 20 odd
grams of protein you need and now i'm
balanced between them both i drink
mostly the banana flavor ready to drink
i've got really into the iced coffee
caramel um flavor of heels ready to
drink and now i'm drinking that as well
as the protein make sure you try the new
ready to drink flavors the caramel
flavor is amazing the new banana flavor
as well as amazing and obviously as i
said the iced coffee caramel flavor has
been a real smash here so check it out
let me know what you think on social
media i see all of your tags and
instagram posts and tweets about huell
[Music]